the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok today teaching equations and how to
teach equations in a way that promotes
long lasting learning and understanding
ok so the first example I'm going to
give you two choices for starting the
example so the first choice so the
example is so this is an example one for
teaching equations and
this is hardy-weinberg equilibrium
so here's one way you could start so if
a locus has n alleles and the organism
is polyploid so that means it has let's
say C copies of chromosomes okay so and
the so there's n alleles and the allele
frequencies so the allele frequencies
are p1 through PN then
we're going to deduce the genotype
frequencies so this is the multinomial
coefficient C choose k1 k2 k3 all the
way to KN and k1 through kN are the
number of copies of each allele with k1
plus follow up to K on all equal to C so
you could actually state that and then
prove it that's option a so now I'll
give you option B for starting the same
topic
option B so option B is from Hardy so in
Hardy's mathematicians apology he writes
I have never done anything useful no
discovery of mine has made or as likely
to make directly or indirectly for good
or ill the least difference to the
amenity of the world that's a very
interesting very bold statement and
amazingly for such a brilliant
mathematician it's wrong and today what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at an example that of a discovery by
Hardy hardy-weinberg equilibrium that
does make a difference to the amenity of
the world and helps you actually
understand genetics okay so the option B
is to quote
party and then show the point out and
then point out the contradiction between
what he said and what we're gonna do now
also in option B you can also go a bit
farther you can say well why would Hardy
have said something like that indeed why
would he have said something like that
in his apology well it's actually
probably hard to appreciate on this side
of the Atlantic because we've never
actually had well since the Civil War
we've never had a war that just
basically devastated entire countries on
our own soil whereas in Europe the
memories of World War one are very
strong so if anyone's from Europe you
know that even you know in every English
Chapel there's names on the wall of all
the people who died in the quote Great
War so it's World War one had a very
strong effect on European society and
one of the effects was on European
science and people's attitude toward
science so the poison gas was invented
you know partly by German chemists haba
was one of them and in the end he
committed suicide partly maybe because
of what he had done he was so yeah did
he could be I think no sorry his wife
committed suicide
I forget that but basically people were
in the family were so unhappy about what
had happened it was there that there was
a suicide and furthermore science after
that was considered you know the world
war one was considered a chemist's war
so there was a wish to distance oneself
from those kind of horrible effects and
the quote from Hardy is actually a
reflection of that he himself was very
strongly anti-war he left Cambridge
because Cambridge fired Bertrand Russell
for protesting World War one so Hardy
left Cambridge for a professorship in
Oxford and only came back basically
twelve or thirteen years later to
Cambridge so that statement of his
is partly a wish that he's hoping
nothing he's done has any effect on the
world because in his mind maybe most
effects are bad well but actually he did
have an effect the effect is
hardy-weinberg even if you discount
everything he did a number theory
there's hardy-weinberg and it has an
effect and we're gonna look at it so let
me ask you a rhetorical question you're
a student which would you find more
engaging more inviting this one or this
one who votes for that one who votes for
that but yeah now why so now think of so
the questions I'm gonna ask you to think
about in just for a minute with one a or
two of your neighbors is why so yeah
this is definitely more engaging in
terms of the principles we talked about
last time
what makes this way of introducing it
more engaging more likely to bring
students in more likely to make them
want to learn about hardy-weinberg okay
so find a neighbor or two and think
about the principles behind option B
okay so
I'll rudely interrupt you and good thing
I did the voice exercise so I can
project all the way to the bath all
right so what reasons for option B more
against option a which is the same thing
yes could you tell me your name
I'm Brian I'm going to try to learn
people's names so good
everybody through the mantra evil fate
or in fact maybe even so he I'm
activating the ability of the students
to basically take dictation or as
someone said teaching is an excellent
way to transfer material from the notes
of the teacher to the notes as a student
without it passing through the minds of
either so I'll call that not a so that's
the not symbol not a is so I'm promoting
dictation which doesn't necessarily I'm
basically asking him to do dictation
which doesn't necessarily would lead to
any kind of learning they could for
example copy all of that down but not
really understand anything okay other
yes could you tell me your name susannah
yeah yep
okay so right and so be is a story or
I'll well you know so here's an example
of how stories are can be so powerful
and just even the work so a big
commercial publisher this was several
years ago they wanted me to write a
freshman physics textbook line I had
actually I just put up a proposal on the
web saying you know we should write a
freshman physics textbook that is based
on history of science and they saw it
they thought oh that's great so they
flew me from England in California to
talk to them and they liked it mostly
but they said mmm history so there was
the word hit they liked the idea as I
talked about it but the word history
really frightened them and then I still
amazed this how I had this amazing
insight of just two letters I thought oh
wait I can actually explain to them what
I mean I said well actually if you just
take away that part what I'm really
talking about is that and it was
interesting as soon as I saw the word
story everybody and they saw that well
history doesn't have to be names dates
facts I think that's what they were
seeing in us they saw it as story which
is actually its origin in French or
Latin
histoire they all of a sudden work
totally convinced they said oh yeah
that's exactly how we should do the
textbook for various reasons basically
because I want it to be a freely
licensed wanted to be a freely licensed
book we didn't actually sign a contract
but it's an example of how powerful
story is and how people who actually
spend their lives thinking about
teaching and reaching students in other
words this commercial this educational
publisher knew the importance of story
but if you present it as just dry
history it's not so yeah interesting
event so story yeah so let's see who
haven't I heard from too haven't heard
adrián yeah and then you're next yeah
okay so there's a contradiction the
contradiction creates some kind of
tension right so that tension creates
interest so right so every good story
needs some kind of tension you know so
the tension here the contradiction is
that you know Hardy wanted to do nothing
that could harm people basically so he
was like okay well anything can be used
could be used even if it's for good for
ill so let me just back off from all of
that say I'm not gonna do anything that
has an effect an application I'm a pure
mathematician his most famous book is a
course of pure mathematics well maybe
his most famous book is that book that I
quoted from a mathematicians apology but
his most famous math book is probably a
course of pure mathematics and that's
what he want to be known for and that's
in contradiction with the fact that no
even Hardy couldn't help an application
and actually a very very common one it's
taught in every single introductory
biology course probably okay so you need
tension now that's a general principle
of learning there you know the idea of
story and tension and paradox so you the
one way that as a undergraduate in
physics that I learned a ton of physics
me and my friends were doing problem
sets together and you know a lot of the
problems were just grinding through math
so we didn't learn a hell of a lot from
that but we were in the library late at
night you know the physics library
ordering pizza and trying to do our
problem set and we just got to making up
physics paradoxes you know perpetual
motion machines we didn't meant
perpetual motion machines and try to get
the other person to figure out what was
wrong with it sometimes we didn't even
know what was wrong with it we both try
to figure it out so from that kind of
tension tension is almost in a way
self-teaching because as long as the
tensions there you know you're not at
the end of the story
right so you know there's more to do so
the same thing as long as there was
perpetual motion going on and we hadn't
found the reason we knew we weren't done
with the problem we didn't have to ask a
teacher to say what was this right
because it was basically
self-teaching as long as the tension was
there we knew that we weren't finished
okay so yeah another general principle
stories intention let's see there was
comment over yes okay so yeah the the
teacher makes himself more human and
makes the person who invented or one of
the people who invented the
hardy-weinberg equilibrium or human so
it's actually something much more easy
easily for the students to connect to
yes could you tell me your name Gregory
very very different amount of background
again it's one maybe more tends to be
because you can this passage is all the
background but I think also at auction a
is pretty interesting because you can
approach this biological problems from
more like qualitative approach but
having on
okay so so Gregor's point which is a
good one is that B doesn't have the same
quantitative depth is a and well
actually what I'm going to show you is a
way to get to this starting from here
and using the principles that we're
talking about so that by the time you
get here or does something like this it
actually makes sense to the students
okay so that you can have both so that's
a promise and hopefully I'll deliver on
it for you okay does that but does that
address what you're talking about that B
doesn't have the quantitative depth and
that's true
you well so you so the point made is
that if you want to get here you do have
to say this at some point and you know
you can't just say the story for now
well it depends on the purpose of the
class if it's the purpose is the history
of biology maybe you continue with the
story or the history of science and war
but if you know you want the students to
be able to solve problems in genetics
you know maybe you need to go here or
what we'll find is the night I'll
continue with option B moving towards a
and I'll show you how you can get there
without and still have the opening of be
preserved okay so let's see there was
yes that's good tell me your name okay
oh okay so B is uh is new right a is
actually so against a a is very familiar
in common so in fact yeah I chose this I
mean I didn't really make a strawman
here this is how a lot of things are
introduced for example in mathematics
class theorem proof right so the theorem
will be introduced without any of the
struggle the wandering that led to the
theorem look why would anyone even care
about such a thing
or if they cared about it why would they
come up with something like that you
know how can you see that the so yeah a
is seem very familiar and therefore
maybe not as interesting although it may
also be intrinsically less interesting
for the other reasons but I take your
point too that it could be just
familiarity yes could you tell me your
name thank you
sort of like we
okay so your your point which is an
excellent one as well is that you be
doesn't preclude the quantitative what
you could do is you could talk about the
history start with the history of Hardy
saying that which is not chronological
because he said that in 1940 but that's
okay it doesn't have to be chronological
just because it's history you go to 1940
and then backtrack to well how did this
problem actually come to Hardy's
attention which is actually it turns out
to be quite an interesting story and
then talk about how they solved it and
what was the publication history all the
quantitative ideas would come out in
that way and it would be in almost
backwards from the usual way in one way
is that the usual way well the usual way
here is completely general and that's
probably not the way it was first
figured out and the advantage of telling
about it that way is that you're
preparing students themselves for a
research career because they're not
nobody comes up with theorems full-blown
you know like a scene out of the head of
Zeus you come through him from struggle
wondering hmm I wonder that everything
has some historical background to it so
the it's called the you could say it the
genetic approach so in biology there's a
slight misstep ssin but as saying that
ontology recapitulates phylogeny in
other words that the organism read has
it developed say in the womb goes
through all the evolutionary stages that
it went through over the last 200
million years or whatever to become a
say a person your first of fish and then
maybe your monkey and then your person
so roughly speaking it's not exactly
true but there's a lot of truth to that
for learning ideas that you have to
recapitulate the history of ideas to
really understand
where we are now the ideas today so a
great example of that is the Newton's
second law of motion
the idea that force and acceleration are
connected so for thousands of years
millions of years people thought force
and velocity were connected and for it's
actually forcing acceleration so
actually you can guide people to the
understanding of forcing acceleration
being connected by showing them the
history of where how people thought it
was force and velocity because for those
same reasons those are the reasons that
students will think it too so you're
actually helping them overcome their
misconceptions so that the history
actually generally speaking helps
overcome misconceptions so I'll get back
here and the history is actually quite
interesting I think it was Punnett from
punnett squares
he played cricket with Hardy and Hardy
loved cricket and he just asked him
about this problem and Hardy said oh
yeah no it's just this and sent off the
paper to science or nature uh-huh so
that's basically is because they were
you know cricket playing colleagues in
Cambridge that's how the you know a
mathematician ended up interested in a
biology problem a pundit was a biologist
okay so any other reasons yes tell me
your name
as the teacher would tell the history
about the people developing quantum
quantum mechanics and that was the
lectures we didn't trust the material
one bit because his blood was what
mature is the book you don't need to
teach you just what we're reading but I
remember being in that class and maybe
that's because you know normally see
things taught like that but everyone was
outraged
because right okay so the yeah the
comment is that well you were in a
actual class that was purely taught
about the history people were outraged
they felt they weren't learning actual
content and there's two answers that one
is that actually I don't recommend if
you say you're really say you're
teaching a physics class that you teach
it purely historically but to the extent
that you do teach the history you can
actually teach the content through the
history so it's not that the history and
the equations or the ideas are separate
it's that you can use the history as the
means of making the equations come alive
with the deeper understanding so it's
possible that the teacher you're talking
about actually didn't do that and just
talked about the people who did this and
did that but he didn't really know what
they did or why so you can you don't
you're not forced to do that okay so
I'll give you an example I'll continue
with this in just a moment after taking
the other questions showing you how you
know you can start with the history and
then you can show the content you can
actually show people exactly why that
would be true and I'll show you that in
one second okay there was a question
there yes sure no sorry not sure can you
tell me your name I know in front
Cecelia yes
Paul yeah
yeah it's genetics yeah right right yeah
I'm gonna do that next
one is like because these I mean I don't
know what story exactly it needs to be
removed from the actual equation this is
yeah sorry it's not directly about that
yeah
that's true so the kook so one question
is how related should the stories be and
there's a lot of freedom in that I mean
I would say the answer is that you want
it to as long if it does this if he
creates interest and it's already done
something now your other point was that
well it depends on the audience
suppose the audience is all graduate
students in genetics or people who want
a crash course in genetics maybe
actually they want to just know the
formulas and they would actually be
offended if you started telling them
stuff that wasn't the formula because
they feel like their times being wasted
a little bit like what you were saying
oh one second all right so now did you
have a comment about that okay and then
I'll come to you in one second all right
so one comment about that is that well
actually most of the students this least
in a big class in genetics are going to
be students who are like for example at
MIT are they're not because they love
genetics and are going to continue in
genetics they're doing it because
they're required to take introductory
biology and your job as the teacher is
to actually show them that this is a
really fascinating subject it's the same
in physics
I mean it's often taught as if the only
students in a physics class were the
physics majors now when I was an
undergraduate in Stanford they were with
1600 undergraduates and 12 physics
majors every year so 1% of the student
body was physics majors so they were
actually teaching in a way generally
speaking for one percent of the student
body and well what about the other 99
percent it was really important for them
to reach them as well important also for
this health and growth of the field
because the field needed people who even
if they weren't professional physicists
who saw the value in the field and the
value in physics so generally speaking
it is actually wise way to reach all of
them now suppose you have people who
just want this the next thing I'm going
to do will show you a way of teaching to
them that they'll actually learn this
better because I guarantee you almost
everyone if you just tell them this and
they take dictation
now they go away you say ok everybody
what did I write down most people can't
reconstruct
they'll say well is this a C or an N in
fact if you look at Wikipedia the
Wikipedia entry is incorrect it actually
I think it has an N over here which it
seems plausible but if you actually
understand the equation ringing out that
can't possibly be right all right
and I think it has an N over here so
they'll actually not really have a
command of the equation so you even for
them you you want to not I mean the
story isn't the proof for them but the
continuation will be valuable for them
so again I'll promise that now there was
a question over there yes so your first
point was that you can add stories as
needed yeah that's true oh I should tell
you who the audience is yeah okay good
point
basic story right right okay so yeah
your comment is that it would be helpful
with with when I give you a example like
this to say okay for the particular
audience what would you do
yeah and I'll try to do that that's a
good point now there was another
question behind Cecelia did you did you
still have a comment okay so there's a
lot of jargon in choice a yes so which
makes it much harder to understand right
you have to almost understand like for
example the multinomial coefficient you
have to keep that in your head as long
as well as well as all these subscripts
keep it all in your head and try to
manipulate that object very difficult
right one of the points about that the
related is the chunking right so if the
chunking paper the idea is that these
you know for a student each of these
things is gonna fill up one of the
chunks lots almost because they're all
needs all new to them you you vote you
flooded the chunking system you've
overflowed it and they can't actually
manipulate this as one object anymore
because it's far too many chunks now you
has a professional fielder like well of
course it's a multinomial coefficient
what else could it be right for you
that's one chunk for the student that's
is it CRN mmm k1 k YK what the hell's K
air is it commas or is spaces in
parenthesis what about brackets I've
never seen something like that shouldn't
they be as many things up here is here
so the way they look at is completely
different every symbol is almost a chunk
so this is just massively overflowing
the chunking so this is sort of related
to them
the jargon yes Scott right right fair
enough
would you be very offense are ii would
you be very offended if i gave everyone
a break for a few minutes and then
finished it
no okay so no finish your comment and
then okay good question so how do i know
when to stop have I like because I don't
want to exhaust people's patience but I
do want to take questions and in this
case there's a phrase American teaching
phrase Saved by the Bell which is that I
don't have to make the decision too hard
because I it's probably time for a break
anyway but how do I make the decision I
partly I listen to people's comments
like it for example suppose I got yet
another comment saying well we still
don't know the equation and I'm saying
for the third time I'll wait I'll show
you a way to get to the equation I think
yeah you know it's probably time for me
to do the equation then I'll take more
questions later all right so you listen
for the tension in people's voice which
is also a good reason to have everyone
do the voice exercise first and free the
tension so that if the tension creeps
back in you know it's something you've
done okay so I'll take more questions
after the break but it's 10:02 by that
clock 10:05 we'll start again you know
you can jump up and down and do jumping
jacks or whatever it takes to get the
blood flowing I'll take a couple more
questions and I'll show you how to
continue it to get towards that in a
perceptive way
okay so let me as promised continue
along the lines not continuing the story
but continuing that approach the
alternative sort of mirror image
approach of a which is to say well okay
what would I do
after telling this story so first of all
I would try to fix some of the problems
in just basically blasting people with
that so I try to make it as clear and
anjaan gandi as possible so as you
notice charging up there right so
imagine a gene with two flavors sickle
cell or not
and two chromosomes so yeah just like
people have two copies of each
chromosome hi okay so now before I
continue what have I done just by doing
that right well first of all I've made
something concrete right it's
sickle-cell or not so right away you can
imagine it right so that's sort of
continuing the idea of a story it's much
easier to imagine a concrete situation
either you have sickle cell anemia or
you don't
Wow or you have a gene for it or a gene
that doesn't cause it and the two
chromosomes so rather than having C
chromosomes
I'm just restricting it to two now you
might think well that's you know that's
a terrible restriction that's a
specialization therefore it's bad no
actually it's good for that reason
because it makes it possible to
understand in the next step the idea
behind that equation and once you
understand the idea then that equation
is not so mysterious and furthermore
what's what's nice about two chromosomes
yeah it's a specialization but yeah we
all have to write there are some plants
that have more and some plants that have
less I think but you know people have
two so it's already interesting to us
just for that reason
okay so then the question is how
frequent
so how frequent are the combinations so
we want to answer how frequent are the
three combinations sickle lowercase s is
not sickle so this is s this is
lowercase s what happened to the fourth
combination what are the only three yeah
it's the same s s this and this are the
same okay so I'd actually ask that too
anytime there's something interesting
you know it should have been four
plausibly could have been four but it's
actually three why three
oh it's a comes because we're actually
lumping these two together okay so how
frequent are those three combinations
well that's provided
by this formula P squared Q squared 2pq
so P so P and Q are the frequencies of s
and little s so this is the okay so now
because you've asked them about the
three versus four this two makes sense
already somehow but how can we make
sense of the P squared P Q and Q squared
and so that's where I would continue
with the following which is this
so here is 0 to 1 and this is P and
that's Q so this is the frequency of
sickle cell this is the frequency of not
sickle cell so right away you have
people's Q equals 1 and then I'll draw
this up here too so I make a square
and I have four regions now so it's not
magic why am I making a square what
about the problem tells me square so I
would ask the cluster
I'm looking for area and why area why
two dimensions because of two
chromosomes so it's this is the earth
see the dimension of dimensions is
eventually going to become this thing so
you can see how we're gonna get there
eventually right so I'm looking for an
area because I have two chromosomes so
now let's just look at these various
areas here is a P squared what's this
area there's Q by P so that's a PQ
that's also PQ and that's Q squared okay
let's look at all our pieces oh we have
a P squared there they have a Q squared
there
oh and P Q P Q 2 P cubed right so in
fact this picture explains the entire
set of frequencies here okay and if you
see this picture there's nothing really
new to understand here in fact all this
picture is is showing is that it's a
picture of P plus Q squared equals 1 so
if people's Q is 1 its square is also
equal to 1 and you break this up into
them four terms group two of them
together and you get three terms three
different kinds of terms you get three
different frequencies so now this square
is actually it's very easy to use
suppose someone tells you that oh sickle
cell anemia people with who have both
genes are 1% in the population well how
many people have what fraction of the
population has no sickle cell gene at
all okay well you just look at the
square the information was that this is
1% so that means this is 0.1 and that's
point one that means at some point nine
that's 0.9 so this here is people with
no sickle cell it is point
one it's at the square actually makes
everything really easy to understand
so now the question is how do you
generalize it well what are some of the
gentle the first generalization I'll do
is I'll say suppose that there are well
I'll ask you should I generalize it to
more dimensions or more different copies
of the gene what's easier to draw more
copies right because more dimensions I
don't know how to draw in three
dimensions but I can draw three copies
oh that's pretty easy so
so now take a piece of paper and just on
your own draw this same figure for three
copies of the gene with frequencies P Q
and R
okay so people have a picture does
anyone want to describe their picture to
me
yep
okay so I do the same I make a P Q and
an R and then I do the same here P Q R
okay so okay so there's a P squared Q
squared R squared
now how many guys that we have nine
squares sub squares three of them are
this there's six more now which is which
of them looks similar so this is a P
cube are there any other p qs yeah one
other right PQ over here and here is a
PR is there a PR this is another PR over
here and here's a Q R and a Q R so we
have P squared that's that guy we have Q
squared R squared and then to PR 2 Q R +
2 PQ okay so that's the generalization
to three copies of the G so it turns out
that all these coefficients 1 1 1 2 2 2
those are binomial multinomial
coefficients
okay so now let's generalize one more so
what have we done there before you just
we've written out this and those are the
nine terms grouped into six so this was
our C so now we know how to generalize P
plus Q plus R to the C equals one if
this is this is two chromosomes this is
C chromosomes
so this is C chromosomes with three
copies well what happens if we have n
copies P 1 C equals 1 and all you have
to do is expand that out you can use a
square and higher dimensions or you can
actually use formulas for math and
that's what that's where these come from
P 1 to the 1 power P 2 to the next power
all the way to P n to the next power and
these guys are the coefficients that
count the multiplicity yes oh they have
to add up to 1 because P plus Q plus R
if you only have three copies three
kinds of gene three flavors of the gene
either you have sickle cell a B or C
let's say then the probabilities are
probabilities probability P yeah just
frequency probability yeah so P plus Q
plus R equals one so if you square it
you still get one so you start from the
idea that P plus Q equals one which is
what we did over here so P plus Q is
equal to one then you square and it's
still equal to one so now you just have
another way of writing one so it turns
out that hardy-weinberg
is all just fancy ways of writing one
okay starting from this picture
we've successively complicated it this
is C equals 2 N equals 2 there's C
equals 2 N equals 3
here is the same thing again here is N
equals three general C here is general
in general C okay so what we've done is
we've basically got here by stages of
successive approach one step at a time
okay so that at every stage it's clear
what is going on I mean what's the core
idea the core idea is the one you just
asked the question about which is that
the frequencies add up to one
P plus Q equals one so if you square the
frequencies you still get one and
there's nothing more than hiring
Weinberg than that yes Julie yes right
to switch
yeah good question so I used flavors
instead of a wheel so right here
imagine a gene with two flavors so
actually probably the best way to do it
is to combine the two so you say flavors
because so the thing so this is a
question of transmitting information to
the student without noise on the channel
so if you say the word allele so this is
again related to chunky if you say the
word allele the problem is that now
you're expecting them to try to
understand this new idea as well as this
new item for their you know taking up
one of their chunks that they have
available so when I initially present it
I would use flavors and then I'd say
okay now we understand the whole idea
the thing is kind of seeped it's not
really part of short-term memory anymore
it's connected to something else that
they know for example this people's
cubicles ones so people see you squared
equals one now it's not taking up so
many chunks anymore now they're ready to
hear the word allele so I'll say okay
you know kalokhe lee we could say
flavors but actually the word in the
literature is alleles so you're at no
point you're overloading the system okay
so it's again it's philosophy based on
say history and chunky yes
yeah you made actually use of the
equation down Oh over there oh no I was
just saying that for your benefit yes
that's a good question good point yeah
okay it's a good point so it was
actually was helpful to actually see the
final goal to to know where you're going
actually that's a good suggestion it's
actually not bad to say okay this is
where we're gonna try to understand I
don't expect you to understand it now
it's full of all kinds of squigglies huh
and then star so for example I may be a
really good way to do this whole thing
would be to start with the hardy story
and say we're gonna talk about
hardy-weinberg say all right what is the
hardy-weinberg say well and it's full
generality it says blah I don't expect
you to make any sense of that right now
let's talk about what the core ideas of
it are with this you approach it sort of
creep up on it bit by bit
successive generalization and then you
get there so actually it's not bad to
leave that on the it's a good idea to
leave that on the board the whole time
so you have a context and a goal that
you're like a mountain peak you're
trying to scale thanks for the
suggestion yes tell me your name Scott
yes
oh the navier-stokes equation right
right I think that's true too and so it
then so a lot of it is teaching is
preference of the instructor you know I
for example happen to really like that
story because I've taught in Cambridge
for a long time and I can imagine Hardy
running into Punnett at the cricket
ground so it's interesting to me so I
can tell it with enthusiasm and I'll and
I think it says something about the
relation of science and society which i
think is important for students to learn
so I might use that story but an
instructor with different purpose might
do it as you say which is say like make
a joke about how impenetrable this is
and say oh but you know it seems really
cryptic but will actually understand
this by the end don't worry and that's a
good way of actually I think you're
right it's a good way of creating and
releasing tension
you use a sickle cell for example and
it's obviously not critical right right
so what level of background so if they
don't know what sickle cell is or maybe
I'd use cystic fibrosis which they're
maybe even less likely to know yeah it
could be adding noise so it's a it's a
flipside it's a two-edged sword so are
you adding noise by saying sickle cells
to someone who doesn't know what it is
say yeah yeah i would add noise so maybe
it's actually worth saying just one
sentence what is sickle cell anemia it's
a mutation of the red blood cells that
makes them take a different shape and
makes you unable to transport oxygen as
effectively on the other hand makes you
more resistant to malaria so actually
that part I wouldn't say at the
beginning I'd say well if it's so bad
can't transport oxygen as well how come
it's still around and just let people
think about that for the day and come
back the next time and tell them the
answer but yeah so I'd probably say one
sentence if the people haven't heard of
sickle cell when I was saying and I was
assuming mentally that they know what it
is but I think you're right moat many
people wouldn't know what sickle cell
anemia is and it's worth saying just one
sentence let's see let me just see if
there's any anyone who hasn't made a
comment or a question yes can you tell
me your name
toka
oh how do you get to how do you get this
piece okay so how do you get this whole
thing okay so let me do that by analogy
so for example suppose let me do C
equals 3 mmm running out of board yes
let me erase this one
and in fact let me just use N equals two
because it doesn't illustrate any new
ideas to crank n up
but the cranking this C up the number of
copies actually makes it important to
see why you need to add them all so
let's do P plus Q cube so this is an
organism with three chromosomes but it's
either sickle cell or not at each spot
okay well let's just actually just write
this whole thing out
you could do it by looking at a cube and
seeing all the chunks but he can
actually just do with algebra too
so there's a P cubed there's a P Q P P Q
there's a P Q so there's a P P Q P Q P
and Q P P so those are all contributed P
squared Q and there's three of them okay
now the three isn't what we're talking
about we're talking about this exponent
here then why why is K 1 all the way up
with KN all is equal to C well let me
just put that one in there what is this
equal those some of those guys is three
the sum of the that's P to the cube Q to
the zero that's also three what's the
next term well there's a three P Q
squared and there's a Q cute well that's
Q cubed P to the 0 that's 0 plus 3 this
is 1 plus 2 it's always three and it's
always a seat why is that well you only
have three products P plus Q
so you have three factors and you get to
choose when you're writing out all the
terms or eight of them and we've
combined them into four groups there's
three here three here one here one there
you get one from each of the factors so
you get one exponent from each factors
so the total of all the exponents has to
be three so once you understand it for
three then this is just for C in general
does that help so that's a good example
actually someone probably would ask that
question or should ask that question and
that's how I would answer it
okay now Cecelia you had another
question yes did you have another
question
yeah you'd think on one hand what are we
proving well we just proved P plus Q
plus R squared equals one right so it
looks like there's no content right how
does that done anything well I would say
there's there's no there's no lesson for
me well what we've learned is that for
example we've learned this why they're
various products here and then what this
thing is we've learned intuitively what
this thing does this thing counts for
the number of copies so in the original
n equals to C equals 2 it was either
there's two copies or one copy of each
of these guys so it adjusted for the
number of copies when you have P plus Q
plus R there's one copy one copy one
copy there's two copies of that one two
of that one two of that one so it's that
factor it's the number of copies factor
okay and then in probability course you
learn how to count those factors in
terms of factorials and that has a
definition in terms of factorials but I
wouldn't focus for example in a biology
course on why it's factorials
necessarily I'd want them to understand
that this thing counts for the number of
factors but actually calculating number
of factors for general C and n wouldn't
be the most my first goal in that course
if I didn't have that
it would have played
right inside terms in the multinomial
expansion so it's it's basically it's
from writing out one equals one so it
seems like oh my god we've done nothing
what have we learned
we just learned one equals one which we
already knew but actually by splitting
up one on the other side you've actually
given meaning to each of the terms on
the other side so this is the frequency
of probability of having three copies of
gene a gene type a and none of the other
type this is the probability of having
three copies two copies of gene a and
one of gene B and this is the
probability of having one of gene a and
two of gene B okay so there's three
because there's different ways of doing
it
that's right because people core these
organism we're talking about common ways
multiple copies of chromosomes in case
yes
what is that yeah so what's the
phenotype in the end and that's where
you're right and so with the sickle cell
so actually that is an advantage so the
point is you know needs to link this
phenotype in the genotype and that's
true actually I release it erase the
sickle cell but actually the sickle cell
is a good example for doing that if you
have no copies of the sickle cell gene
well then you're perfectly healthy if
you have two copies of the sickle cell
gene your sickle cell anemia what
happened if you have one copy of the
sickle cell gene well you do have some
symptoms of it but so the question is
well why do you why does that gene
survive well it's because you're
actually more malaria resistant well
that's one of the theories so somehow
the I guess the malaria parasites can't
eat those red blood cells as well
because they have a different shape or
can't invade it so it actually gives you
some advantage and some disadvantage but
they're sort of balanced and yeah if you
have full-blown sickle cell with two
sickle cell genes then you're in trouble
but that's much rarer than the 2pq as
long as Q is small enough okay so then
you can actually then continue that
example you can look at the frequency of
sickle cell gene in different
populations and say okay well is it
higher in areas where there's malaria
and test that theory okay yes
good question yeah so I think you're
right so the I did this kind of
mathematically compared to maybe how
you've taught it to biology students and
yeah I guess I'm implicitly assuming but
I didn't say and I should say is that
this is MIT students I'm just in the
back of my mind thinking MIT students
all right but hadn't didn't make that
assumption explicit so yeah MIT students
are perfectly happy with squaring
binomials and trinomials
you know trinomials usually and to the C
power you're sort of stretching it but
it's okay but generally that way of
doing things for them is good I if it's
people English majors yeah you're right
I would try to actually do it even more
conceptually but one thing that's good
for all of them is the picture because
once you see the picture then you
actually understand the idea in one
grasp it's no it's really just one chunk
now oh it's just a square in four pieces
okay it's just different way of writing
one you know this is one area one and
it's four pieces so that I would keep no
matter who I would talk to and the
question is how much would I lead up to
it this
why
yy-you can't go in with a so I think
brother action between say that areas
let's play
I think you're right so the what you're
saying is that you can't just launch in
with this because even though you could
giving so you gave really exact
definitions of what all these things are
it's not clear that exact definitions
are computationally productive for a
student right yeah they may have the
exact definitions but they can't
actually use it like for example let's
do an exact definition of chess I'll
tell you all the rules of chess and
that's enough of a exact definition to
be able to decide what the best first
move in chess is but it's
computationally useless I still don't
know what the best first move is even if
I know the rules of chess so just
telling you the student all the rules
that say define what a genotype is and
what's polyploidy doesn't mean they can
actually use it in any problem so if you
want transfer all these things have to
have meaning for them and that's what
the goal of this approach is now I think
the approach has been improved from your
suggestions I wanted to show you a
direction they go but I think you've
actually taken it farther and extended
it and improved upon it and the general
principles above all of them are that
you want to I would say one of the key
ones is chunking you want to not
overload the chunk system you want to
somehow bring people in so they even
listen to you if they don't listen to
you if they don't care the learning is
gonna be so much less so all of those
are for that you know so the dictation
of jargon opposed chunking and these all
go together okay
so now what I want to do is give you a
or a short answer to one of the
questions that was raised earlier how do
you become a good teacher the reason I
want to do that is that it's exactly the
same thing if you understand how you
become a good teacher you understand how
you become good at anything how you
become good at chess how you become good
at biology how you become good at
solving physics problems how you become
good at solving I play in concert piano
so if that's what you want to teach your
students to be good at those things well
you want to understand that in a context
say that you're working on say being
good teacher and to do that there's the
there's a following set of experiments
so projectors okay so the way I'm going
to illustrate this is I'm going to show
you a chess position and the goal is to
try to remember the chess position
we'll give you two more seconds
okay so everyone got the position now
I'm gonna ask you instead of to remember
it exactly to reconstruct it
how many pawns were there right okay
that would be eat that so who votes for
a okay who votes for B nine pawns who
votes for C eleven pawns who votes for D
13 ponds who votes for E none of the
above
okay so let me show you you know then
I'll explain why I asked you this
particular question so they're actually
11 now that is it's a very hard task
alright so this actually this very task
not counting the number of pawns I made
that slight variation but the so called
reconstruction task was given to chess
players of various abilities Grandmaster
/ master is one group what I called
experts experts are people who are not
quite chess masters but close in chess
lingo and then Class A players which is
basically strong tournament players so
they were given the task of looking at a
position for four to five seconds the
position was knocked down and they were
asked to reconstruct it as accurately as
they could
okay so it's even harder than the task
of counting the number of pawns so the
results
the results are very striking
so by level of chess player so class a
is the strong tournament players experts
or grandmaster or master so the percent
correct fifty-one percent of the pieces
correct 72 or 93
so the grandmasters the masters are
amazing I mean and in fact for the
number of pawns
I don't think they ever make mistakes on
that because pawns are you know one of
the things that you just know is a
really strong chess player
so ninety-three percent correct and
that's amazing so now what so there's a
related story which is you know about
the memory of chess players which is
some Bobby Fischer yes
come I'll come to that in one second
all right so Bobby Fischer was playing
he was in a tournament and some strong
master was playing in it and Bobby
Fischer went to the bathroom and as he
went to the bathroom he happened to see
that master playing a game and just
continued walking and then about six
months later he ran into him at another
tournament and said Oh Fischer said to
him oh you know in that position in that
tournament did you play blah and the guy
said well all actually had no idea what
the position was even oh and Fischer
said Oh probably set up the board and
said we'll see this is the thing you
really need to do and by then he sort of
remembered but you know Bobby Fischer
remembered it at one glance six months
later so what's a natural conclusion
from this data right you'd say well
naturally grandmasters and masters they
just came with better you know they were
born with better visual memory but in
fact the crucial experiment was then
done in 1973 so these this experiment
was done in basically 1948 by de Groote
what chase and Simon did in 1973 was
that they showed positions that were
random so they showed they redid the
experiment you know they confirmed these
results and then as you suggested they
showed just positions where the pieces
were scattered arbitrarily over the
board and then everyone was basically at
like 12% give or take 1 or 2% and just
random variations in cancer roughly so
what does that show it's not that the I
mean maybe Bobby Fischer was an
exception but for almost everybody else
even the very strongest players it's not
that they're born with a better visual
memory it's that they've learned somehow
a way of looking at chess positions that
there's less to remember for them ok but
so now let's compare here when the
student sees this there's a ton for the
student to remember just like when we
look at a chess position every piece is
separate right but what is a chess
player see when a chess master looks at
a chess position so I'll put the
position back I'll show you what the
chess master sees the chess master sees
something very different they see groups
of related pieces together
so for example here the the chess master
sees this King here is not a surprising
thing for this chess master that's when
you castle your king that's where it
goes
then the rook goes next to it and then
you usually move your rook into the
middle so that's not surprising this
rook is also not surprising the second
one because it usually comes from this
corner into the middle so all this
almost contains no information for the
chess master right here these three
pawns aren't you know very common with a
castle King on that side but then it
looks kind of strange there's some new
information there because maybe this
King Castle but then the rook went all
the way to the corner so actually maybe
black never castled and his King just
sort of wandered into this area hmm what
does that suggest it suggests that the
black King is really vulnerable maybe
it's time for an attack and in fact
pretty sure this is a position from one
of Garry Kasparov's games and in fact
that is the right conclusion the right
conclusion is that it's now time to
sacrifice your knight and take this pawn
and draw the King out and he actually
won using that by sacrificing his knight
so the chess master looks at it
completely differently than the novice
I'm a novice when I play chess to me
every piece is a new bit of information
I'm way over loaded past my chunk
threshold I can't hardly remember the
board at all so your students are in
exactly the same position when they're
learning material that for you you're
the chess master so you're teaching
hardy-weinberg well clearly you've been
appointed to teach hardy-weinberg
because you have a PhD in biology you
know a lot of biology you're the biology
master so this doesn't surprise you that
much right before the student every
single almost letter in there is news to
them so what you want to do is you want
to find ways of thinking about it that
you can group the ideas into chunks so
here is almost one chunk example the
idea that really it's just P plus Q
squared and there's a picture for it
okay and once you understand that well
there's another chunk there's another
idea which is well you could actually
have three
copies of the three kinds of flavors
instead of two ok people's cue posts are
well I can transfer it there oh and then
once you understand that it could
transfer to end copies
once you have any flavor sorry not
copies now you can increase the number
of copies of the chromosome so into two
dimensions three dimensions four
dimensional picture so then you can
actually make sense of all this and give
a way of understanding the position and
not too long ago there's a I think not
well enough known paper I'll put the
reference on the website which shows the
relative importance of say symbolic
calculation versus perception so this is
a perceptual mode so so much of our
teaching is let's say left brain very
very symbolic well there was a really
interesting study done of chess
grandmasters in fact of the strongest
chess grandmaster they garry kasparov
what's the relative importance of
perception perception versus analysis in
his really strong chess play so the way
they tested that there was a really good
experiment is he plays simultaneous
exhibitions all the time so way you do a
simultaneous exhibition is there's for
example 30 or let's say 10 opponents and
you just go around one opponent after
another they have the full time say
three minutes to think until you come
back but as soon as you get to a board
you just think for about five or six
seconds maybe 10 and make a move there
go to the next board so that by the time
you come around back to that same
opponent they've had their a couple
minutes to think so now he plays
simultaneous exhibitions with against
very strong grandmasters and you can
then measure his performance there so
what why is that a good experiment
well he's now not able to do all of his
calculation that he does normally
randy's normally able to think for three
minutes maybe five minutes and do a
whole bunch of analysis symbolic
computation but when he has like five
seconds ten seconds to think mostly it's
perception well his chess rating
effectively dropped by maybe 50 or 60
points so 50 or 60 points to give you an
idea his chest rating is play the
highest in the
it dropped to a level which only five
people in the world are higher so it's a
very small drop right so he still plays
incredibly strong chess better than
almost every other Grandmaster on the
planet so pure almost purely with
perception so what that shows is that
the way Kasparov has become so good and
in general experts have become so good
is that they look at the world
differently their perception is
different so if you want so how do you
do that as a teacher okay that's one
question how do you promote that in your
students well you want to give them ways
of looking at the world that change
their perception that's why I'm so
focused on the say the story the tension
the human the right brain the pictures
the chunking because it's those that are
actually producing long-term expertise
whereas this is producing what would be
st. equivalent of say programming a
chess computer but that doesn't work
that may work for chess computers to
play a good chess but it doesn't
actually work for people to be able to
use the knowledge later so now what
produces that so there's a one short
answer which is that for teaching you
want to change your perception of how
students think okay if you have a
correct new good perception of how
students are thinking well then you're
actually able to make teaching judgments
on the fly you can plan your chest your
sorry chest move your lecture and like a
chess game you your intuition is right
so you want to tune your intuition well
that is why I do this
I found the single most important thing
that has improved my teaching and I
highly recommend is the feedback sheet
because for example I learned what was
confusing and question 1 and in question
2 I learned what works and what doesn't
work so as I see what works and doesn't
work I start to build up a more and more
accurate model of you and I start to be
able to plan and reason about how to
teach you and in general how to teach
students so I'll talk about that more
that's the idea of deliberate practice
and expertise I'm going to talk about
that more in the subsequent sessions and
in more detail and show you some of the
studies
around that but the general rule is you
want reflective quick feedback on what
you're doing in order to become an
expert okay and that's true whether
you're in teaching concert piano physics
problems whatever it may be so with that
said if you can fill out the sheet so
that I can become a better teacher
that's be very helpful and see and one
announcement which is that next week is
is a Tuesday MIT is open on Tuesday
except it's Monday schedule of classes
so we don't have a class on next week
the week after that I'm a witness in a
administrative law trial so I'm not here
so there's no class for the next two
weeks so we'll meet again in three weeks
and I'll post some readings and a short
problem set for you to work on some
readings growing out of what we've done
today okay so if you could bring up your
sheet and your index card then two
separate piles that would be very
helpful and question there's gonna be
another class coming in in a big class I
think so
I'll just go outside and answer any
questions that people have right outside
so that the new class can come in okay
answers from lecture three two questions
generated in lecture two
I'm gonna first answer questions from
before since there were lots of
questions and all interesting and I'm
also going to do another equation
example there was lots of requests for
another equation example to see how it
plays out in a different field and a
different way of approaching equations
not just from the entry point of a story
so I'll show you that and then we're
gonna look at misconceptions in various
fields and the fundamental importance of
understanding that so that you can
understand how to change your teaching
and how to reach the students basically
if you can't understand where they are
you can't come to them so questions from
before all right one comment was that I
don't often were often enough summarized
the end result with the transferable
lessons for later so thanks for that
suggestion and I'll make sure to do that
another question was graduate versus
undergraduate classes exam we talked a
fair amount about the audience a bit
last time in response to questions so
how do you change your teaching in
response to questions in response to the
change in audience so the particular
question here is graduate versus
undergraduate classes and the sense I
got from some of the questions was that
somehow you it's harder to do what we
were talking about last time which is
teaching equations in an intuitive way
in a graduate class than an
undergraduate class actually in some
ways it's the opposite all right it's
true that generally in graduate classes
people just put up a ton of equations
for example in quantum field theory you
just get gazillion integrals with
epsilon floating all over the place and
then path integrals you integrate this
and there's some two PI's and take a
bunch of limits and it seems like a
whole bunch of math gymnastics but hey
it doesn't have to be that way and also
there's another characteristic of
graduate students which you don't have
so much with undergraduates which is
that graduate students know how to read
now this may seem like a bizarre
statement because surely everyone knows
how to read by say age 3 or 4 or 5 or
whenever they teach reading in school
least
not but what I mean is that
undergraduates generally they they have
a no experience on how to read a
textbook because they've had so much
experience with us telling them stuff
everything on the board so they have no
incentive to actually read the textbook
and they don't learn how to do that they
think textbooks are read the way you
read Jane Austen novels you just read
you read for plot okay something
happened to some equation then something
else happen to some equation and you
just sort of carry on paragraph by
paragraph as you would a novel that way
of reading is completely hopeless for
technical material but graduate students
not always but generally have much more
maturity about this so graduate students
actually can or off-hour closer to being
able to read technical material with
skill for example graduate students
often read papers in their own field and
you know you have to read a paper
differently than you would a Jane Austen
novel so because of that you can
actually teach equations very
differently what you do is you give all
the long messy yucky parts you leave
that for the notes for the book you know
somewhere where everything is printed in
a very easy to read format rather than
copying long long long long strings of
symbols off the board so that connects
back to what we talked about last time
was his chunks so if you put long
equations up on the board generally you
will overflow the chunk system and once
that happens people start making
mistakes so you want to avoid doing that
as much as possible and with graduate
students that's even easier to do
because you leave all that on for a
typeset professionally published book or
you know typeset by yourself but somehow
printed in a clean way with no mistakes
and you can then in class discuss the
meaning of the terms what are the terms
where do they come from why would you
expect that kind of term so I'll give
you an example of doing that with an
equation today but generally speaking
you all what I was talking about last
time applies perfectly well to graduate
classes even if people at first think
that it doesn't so I should say if any
questions occur to you as I'm answering
questions you know basically questioning
begetting questioning
please raise your hand and ask them that
and right now okay I found that the
square diagram muddied the development
of the hardy-weinberg equation so the
square diagram was this one so the
conclusion from that was the question
which is shouldn't college students be
comfortable with the expanding P plus Q
squared why do they need a diagram and
the answer isn't that people absolutely
aren't comfortable with expanding
peoples Q squared although you will find
people for whom this and this is just a
symbol replacement strategy in other
words it's something like you program at
a computer whenever you see this pattern
do this but the terms don't actually
have meaning for people they don't know
why those terms are that way and if
they'd miss memorize it and put cubes
here they would write that down too so
the picture actually makes it clear what
the meaning of the term is so it gives
actually meaning to what people might be
otherwise comfortable where they're
having done from lots of practice so I
should say there's a difference between
just rote matching between here and here
versus this kind of understanding and
that's illustrated by the following
research in which is about people's
ability to multiply and add when people
have brain damage so the technical term
is brain lesions so people with brain
lesions in the see if I can say this
right so people with brain lesions in
the arithmetic areas lose their ability
to add but they can multiply fine and
people with brain lesions in the verbal
areas they lose their ability to
multiply but they can add fine
okay now this seems kind of strange
right so why would multiplication and
addition not go together when you lose
when you get brain damage in the
arithmetic area so so the damage so if
the damage is either an arithmetic or
verbal here's what you lose so
arithmetic area damage you lose addition
here you use multiplication and that is
very bizarre because you think well you
should lose multiplication here too and
the reason is that it doesn't work that
way is because of the way multiplication
is generally learnt and taught so how do
so in for example in England the way
it's thought is so this is research from
Brian Butterworth in England the way
multiplication is taught in England is
in a multiplication table same as here
and people memorize it as six 9s is 54
right so six 9s is 54 or here I think I
learned multiplication both places so 6
times 9 is 54 either way that's a purely
linguistic string right it's it's no
surprise that when you lose verbal
ability you lose the ability to memorize
linguistic strings so the multiplication
table went right so what that tells you
is that most people and I don't know if
this is true for everyone but my guess
is it depends on how you learnt the
multiplication table for most people
they've learnt the multiplication table
in a way that is not meaningful right
they've learnt the multiplication table
purely linguistically and that is the
problem with just going down this path
only which is that again this is where
it's important to know where students
come from if you know students basically
have just linguistically memorized this
transformation to that transformation
sort of like the rock bands in other
countries that sing in English they know
when they see English words they know
what to say but they don't necessarily
understand any of the words
that is actually very common and this is
another linguistic transformation
there's no meaning underneath it so here
to give it some meaning underneath it
some picture it actually incorporates
another brain area into the
understanding right which is where
addition actually has some meaning to
people so that brings up a related
question into which is well if people
have learned multiplication in this
linguistic way how could you teach it in
a non linguistic way so that people
actually understand it well there are
several ways you I don't know of any
studies that show that after doing it
this way and then brain damage it
doesn't get lost
but my speculation is that if you learn
it actually puts pretty much the way I
learnt it you wouldn't actually lose it
and the way is for example suppose you
have to multiply 6 times 9 rather than
memorizing that is 54 you think about
what it should be and you reason your
way to it you think oh well that's
slower
yeah it's slower in the beginning but in
the end you get to the same place but
you put it in a different part of the
brain so the way you could do this one
for example you say oh 6 times 9 well
that's 6 times 10 which is really easy
minus 6 so 6 times 10 you know not by
memorizing but from understanding the
number system so you know that that's 60
because of the way the number system
works you don't have to memorize that
that's the kind of example where I think
calculators should be programmed to
self-destruct or at least not work for
about a week if you type in a problem
like that they should just freeze has
incentive to actually think about these
things before you put them into the
calculator so minus 654 so now that's a
bit longer the first time you do it it's
longer than memorizing it but after you
do multiplication a bunch of times like
this you actually you reinforce the
meaning of the number system and you
come up with the same answer and
eventually you will memorize it but
you've memorized it in a different way
here's another example
let's say from the 12 times table 8
times 12 now should you memorize that as
96 no you should write that as 10 minus
2 times 10 plus 2 so that's equal to 10
squared minus 2 squared equals 96 right
and you can even draw a picture for this
and show what happens to squares in area
so again you come up with the same
answer but you've done it in a
meaningful way okay so that's one answer
to why it's worth showing pictures even
if people can do the algebra it
reinforces the algebra okay is
determining what constitutes a chunk
simply a matter of my intuition about
students level well to some extent it is
but in the chess-playing research i
talked about they actually had ways of
some more objective ways of determining
what a chunk was and what they did is
they put eye trackers on people and they
had the chess masters in the non chess
masters and the experts look at the
board and they tracked their eyes to see
what they did so the non chess masters
you know they're I sort of wandered all
over but the chess masters looked at
pieces in groups they would go here here
here here and then here here here here
and the assumption was that that's a
chunk and then that's a chunk or if they
went here then to there that some of
these two chunks were related so there
was ways in the chess plating problem of
measuring chunks and then how do you
apply that to teaching physics well
that's a matter of partly of intuition
and the idea is to help the students
build up the chunks so you have to be on
the watch for what chunks you use so you
have to introspect okay
okay how do you keep things interesting
and reveal material in a time
appropriate way so the comment was that
it took a while to do the hardy-weinberg
with the story and then building up to
it so this is a question of how do you
plan lecture time what's worth doing in
lecture is it worth spending a bunch of
time on understanding the concepts and
there's two extremes to this I mean I'm
basically tours one extreme which is
that if you don't understand the
concepts it's not even worth learning
the thing because if you don't
understand so as a student if you don't
understand the concept you might as well
just forget the material right now
because you're gonna forget it soon
anyway so the only benefit from taking
the course if you don't understand the
material is you just get a grade on a
final exam and you could pass a
requirement but in terms of actually
changing how you see the world it has no
value so there was a study done I think
at Carnegie Mellon yes it was at
Carnegie Mellon they studied freshman
physics students so they had students
who took freshman physics and students
who didn't take freshman physics and
then a year later they gave them the
freshman physics final exam I think it
was the same one pretty much as the
students who took freshman physics took
accept you know with numbers change but
otherwise the same problems to see
whether taking freshman physics had any
effect on whether you did well on a
freshman physics final year later and
the conclusion was that it had no effect
my year later so yeah sure if you give
him the final the next day after the
final exam that they took they were done
pretty well maybe fifty percent who
knows what the time constant is but
certainly by a year it was gone so you
know what that tells me is that that
regular way of teaching material
actually did no good to the students
except for passing requirements but no
intrinsic good for their way of
analyzing the world so what that says is
then you really need to find something
different and yeah if it means it takes
extra time and lecture a bunch of time
and lecture so be it at least people
will understand something so and they
will change how they see the world and
that's the motive for today which is to
really understand misconceptions because
if you don't understand the
misconceptions you're not going to be
able to teach in a way that produces
long lasting learning
okay so another one was how do I apply
this to something really abstract the
way of approaching equations like the
proof of this is actually one of my
favorite infinite series so the question
is how do you apply it to something
really abstract like this so this is a
famous infinite series what's the sum of
that and it turns out to be PI squared
over 6 well even that you think oh how
can I apply to that well it turns out
there's there's great stories about that
one too
I think this is I think this is a story
about this problem which is that no one
knew how to do this sum from 1 to
infinity it's quite a hard sum and so it
was set as a problem basically for the
mathematicians and physicists of Europe
and then someone produced a solution I
think someone produced a solution
anonymously and everyone basically
figured out who had done it because it
had their handy mark so the solution was
by Euler and it involved a whole bunch
of trickery with polynomials and
infinite degree polynomials and it was a
really sly method alright so that so if
I was going to teach this equation I
would actually teach the history of it
how it was really hard how you could
actually guess this what are ways you
could guess this well you could actually
approximate the sum get a number that's
one or two or three digits accurate and
then you feed it into does everyone know
this guy if you google for that you
should probably find it it's called the
inverse symbolic calculator that's a
fantastic thing I do not know how it
works and I would love to know how it
works but what it is is you feed in a
number and it will tell you all the ways
of producing something really close to
that so for example if you put in 3.14
one it'll say well that's it'll say one
two numbers that get near here and one
of them is pi if you put in this to one
or two or three digits
it'll probably guess for you PI squared
over 6 so that's one way of getting at
an answer so part of the way of teaching
it is to say well let's somehow get
answer with Wayans we can do that aren't
too abstract and then let's see if we
can justify that answer so even there
you're not lost there's always stuff you
can do okay
so whoa another question which was
readings how do you incorporate readings
into a course so that students do it so
that was asked twice actually
because I didn't answer it the first
time so readings one way to do readings
is something called reading memos and
it's an MIT invention now by Edwin
Taylor who's recently retired from the
physics department and what a reading
memo is I'll put up the handout so I've
often done this in my classes and I'll
put up the handout for you to use that I
give out and you can just copy it or do
whatever with it so a reading memo is a
request to the students to write you a
short memo about something that you've
asked them to read it could be the draft
notes for your textbook that you're
working on which is what I often do it
with or it could be the textbook someone
else wrote and you ask the students to
read a chapter and what it's not is it's
not a summary of the text because you
already know what the text says there's
no point getting a summary what it is is
students reactions to it
so anything that questions things that
puzzled them oh I didn't understand why
you did this
or the author did this and then maybe
three pages later oh now I see which if
you're the author of those notes you
know that you explain the two things out
of order and you should connect them but
what that does is it makes the student
teaches the students how to read
actively because again like I talked
about people just do Jane Austen's
approach to reading technical material
and by getting students to read actively
and formulate questions by doing that
students learn a different way of
reading a way necessary for reading
technical material and by also by
writing their questions down and you
seeing the questions you actually get a
view into how the students are thinking
so it's actually a way of
understanding what their misconceptions
are their conceptions of the field are
and tuning your teaching just
automatically or find your teaching well
impedance match to where the students
are just by reading the reading memos it
has a further benefit which is that it
inverts the normal power relationship
between teacher and student so for
example most assignments problem sets
there's the correct answer which you
know and you're seeing whether they know
the correct answer so they're now
writing an answer worried whether
they're correct or not and then you're
judging them so normally he said the
power hierarchy is you and then their
student down here and the student is
looking up to you for validation so now
this is not a good thing to teach I mean
it's hard to avoid with problem sets but
I mean you have to do problems that
somehow and teach people to do problems
what do you want to minimize this as
much as possible because that's not a
transferable way of dealing with the
world right they can't use that when
they go elsewhere then it teaches bad
habits of deference to Authority so
that's normal what how does a reading
memo work well it's the other way around
if the student says this is confusing
well by definition they are correct it's
confusing they are the expert on what's
confusing or not right so it it inverts
the hierarchy to this and you become
very interested in what the students are
saying right they are the experts now
and I've had very good results with
doing reading memos and my explanation
is that it's because of this inversion
of power hierarchy now what do I mean
also by good results two things one is
that I get fantastic feedback on the
things I'm writing the other is that I
find students actually want to do
reading memos after the class finishes
they say oh if you have more notes can
we just do some more reading memos say
great let's do that and it's because
it's actually I mean if you write good
problems that so often say can we do
more problem sets but that requires a
fair amount of work to minimize the
hierarchy but it's automatically here in
the correct hierarchy so students
actually enjoy doing that and want to
continue okay so that's one
excellent way of incorporating readings
into class so now the problem is what do
you do when you have 50 people in a
class and you get 50 memos so I've had
this problem and one thing I do is I
just feel overwhelmed and I just flipped
through them but I don't know what to do
but another is I revise my notes based
on it but the I think correct solution
is an online system so what you want is
an online system where you can post a
PDF file and then people make comments
on the PDF file so everyone gets to see
say an image of the page and they can
just click and make a comment and
everyone gets to see their own comments
and then when they submit them they get
to see everyone else's comments so I
actually wrote half of that system and
there's a graduate student in EECS who I
think has now written the whole system
independently of me so I'm gonna try it
out and see how it works and tried in
some of my classes this semester so the
benefit of that is that you can then see
all the comments at once rather than
flipping through 50 sets of reading
memos with page numbers on them okay
how do I come up with intuition examples
how do I know if what builds intuition
for me will also build intuition for the
students it's a very good question right
is it just my personal opinion or is it
just the teachers personal opinion and
one of the whole themes about this class
is yes teaching does have a fair amount
of art and there is a fair amount of
personal opinion in it but there's also
a fair amount of science and things you
can do to make it more objective and one
of them is actually to do reading memos
you actually any way you can to learn
how students think will make it so that
your intuition about the students
actually matches how the students really
think that's the whole purpose of today
about talking about misconceptions
reading memos are a way of understanding
what students think so so once you
understand what students think it's much
easier to realize just intuitively
choose things that you know are going to
work for them the other way is the
feedback sheet so every time the
students tell you oh this really helped
me where this really didn't help me at
all you now have one more piece of
feedback about what works for them and
what doesn't work for them okay so then
you can actually choose intuition
examples how do you invent them from
scratch well there are some general
principles like one is use pictures
whenever you can generally that speaks
to people's intuition just because
people have much more Hardware for
pictures than they have for equations so
I try to find whenever I try to put
myself in the position of the student
and I say well for example here
I say yeah this all these equations may
well be true but I want a way that makes
me see it instantly and that just forces
me to start looking for pictures okay
and that tease me actually towards what
students need okay so you can do the
same right okay I think that was most of
the questions the other questions were
similar to that and I'll answer any that
were new that I haven't answered but I
think most of them I have answered at
the beginning of the next lecture so any
questions that were generated by the
questions
yes question
yeah
right so the quiet comment was what I
said about even a year of intense
freshman physics maybe was a semester I
forget if it was just mechanics but he
was either one semester or a whole year
of freshman physics did no good towards
long term understanding and change of
understanding of freshman physics well
what does that say about these big
survey classes where you're not expected
to understand they so in freshman
physics at least they have the
expectation that you're supposed to
understand everything now what about the
courses where they start with the
expectation that you're not going to
understand most of it Madonna is going
to be totally hopeless then I think that
is basically true and maybe could
justify it back in the day when let's
say 400 years ago when books were even
let's say when books were around and but
there was no web ok people need to know
what books are out there so this is a
traditional thing in Cambridge for
example they just give people think huge
reading lists so then you go back later
you're like ok these are the key books
in the area ok so you know one place to
go for a reading list that's kind of
obsolete now with the web right if you
if you want to find out something for
example suppose there's a equation I
didn't know about let's say the I don't
know black Scholes equation alright
would I say hmm
I wonder if I have took any classes
about black Scholl No maybe let me go
flip through all my course notes no
right you just type it into the some web
search and see what shows up and that is
much more likely to be more relevant
than some notes that you might have had
or not had so yeah I think the survey
courses are completely pointless alright
now that doesn't mean that introduction
to a field is pointless but it means
that the way to do the introduction has
to be very different
you can't just scatter a bunch of topics
of people what you have to do is figure
out and we're going to talk about this
when we talk about course design you
have to figure out what are the core
reasoning ideas that a special to that
that that field has to offer the world
for example history what's special about
history well historians have
sense of how to evaluate the validity
and reliability of evidence and
contradictory evidence that's something
you don't get in many other fields for
example it's sort of in between a
science and a pure literature's field
like in just straight literature reading
novels I mean there's historical
evidence and things but generally you're
reading in a different way in math it's
hard to know where contradictory
evidence comes in although they're ways
of teaching math which I like which do
that but generally in history has
something new to offer which is you know
it's a messy world not Ollie you know
you have noisy evidence what do you do
well that's something that a intro
survey course could actually teach right
in that somebody could transfer even if
they don't remember you know when did
the Magyars invade Europe and all the
random stuff that would be in a survey
course so those would be grist for the
mill hung off a big ideas so I'm gonna
talk about that when we talk about
courses I'd but yeah you're right that
course design is completely hopeless
that general big survey other questions
yes yeah yes could you tell me your name
Megan what was your name Amy thank you
so
Universal
yeah that's it okay that's a good
question so maybe it was a slightly
unfair test because they were just
tested out of the blue and right right
so if they've taken courses that use
freshman physics throughout maybe they
would have remembered the freshman
physics cutter and I'm sure that that's
true so I can tell you one story from
graduating my graduate time so I had to
do a PhD I did a PhD in physics not to
do the qualifying exam and to do the
qualifying exam you have to study a
whole bunch of undergraduate physics and
then taking exams on it all right now
what I remember and then you take a
bunch of courses in various fields now
the only thing basically I remember from
all electromagnetism is one thing which
is I understand pretty well the index of
refraction and why is that that's
because I was really pissed off I'm
sorry for the camera I was really
annoyed about the following thing I so
this actually goes back to what I was
talking about about contradictions which
is that you're always told in relativity
that speed of light
equals C and that's the great postulate
of relativity that the speed of light
does not change damnit right and that's
what Einstein said and there's all these
experiments with thought experiments
with trains and lightning bolts and
people throwing rocks from the train at
different speeds and it's C it's C it's
C and then somewhere later in
electromagnetism courses hell yeah the
speed of light in a medium with an index
of refraction in is C over N where n is
typically around 1 maybe a little bigger
like 1.0 1/4 oh sorry 1.01 for air maybe
1.33 for class and how do those fit
together
right so that really annoyed me and I
wanted to get even get to the root of it
and say well how could it be that you
could have a speed of light that's
always C yet it looks like the speed is
some lower number V so I worked out a
whole bunch of stuff about how electrons
scatter radiation and all the scatter
radiation adds up and makes it seem like
it's slowing down the light and because
of that I actually understand this and
also because of that which may be not so
good every time there's an
electromagnetism problem I have to do I
always try to fit it into a scattering
problem and if I can't do that then I
just can't do it at all and that's
despite taking two years of
electromagnetism one two years is
undergrad and one year as reviewing as a
grad student so what I the point I'm
trying to make by that is that most
stuff disappears and the way to really
make stuff stay is you really have to
struggle with something all right and
and that's the most efficient way to
make something stay and that's not what
happens in your traditional class and
even less in a survey class
right so maybe you need to see something
a few times to really understand it or
it may be that you so if a class doesn't
give you that chance and you have to
take thermo too and then thermo three
right so you should try to build that
into the class so that's there's a name
for that which is called the spiral
curriculum and there's a lot of sense to
that so I'll just put any quick so you
show the idea in its crude form and then
you spiral back to it in a more
sophisticated way but you'd like to do
that soon before the connection is gone
right before this is actually wafted
away you want to spiral back to it and
so you'd like your class to do that so
what that shows is that you should start
with the big ideas and then you should
refine them because if you start with
all the little details here you'll just
flood the chunking system and actually
there'll be no memory of it here and
there to start over from scratch here
you had a question could you tell me
your name let me go yeah yeah
ask questions
that's actually
so I wonder okay so your comment the
comment is that a class that actually
implemented in the online annotation
system they found that the comments are
too micro level and not broad enough
about you know what's really confusing
or interesting and that so I haven't
tried the online system myself yet what
I do know is that on the paper if you do
it on paper you get really insightful
detailed comments now I don't know what
variables are different one might be
that the online system just encourages
because everyone does things quick
online it encourages quick clicking so
it may be that encourages less depth of
thinking whereas writing it on paper I
actually find I get a mix of a whole
bunch of like not trivial comments but
small comments like okay some typos oh
that equation isn't quite right but then
I get things like oh I don't see the
picture here or I don't understand why
you did this now and that to my mind is
a useful comment or a question like why
that can't be right because of the
following counter-argument so on paper I
get a lot of interesting things so it
may be that online isn't as good and
that's one reason I want to try it and
see so it may be that they need to go
back to paper despite of being harder
another is also what is the material if
the material is really boring you're
gonna get really Micro comments so it
helps to actually have written
interesting material or give people
interesting stuff to read that people
are likely to think about and make
comments
question me your name Brian yes
versus terminologies
- if you want to describe the
relationship between stress and
stranding and period you want to call
her folks along or if you just want to
call the concision
right okay so good the question is I
what about naming equations should you
name them by who made them or by how
their use or what they are so another
example of that is for example the fluid
mechanics equation should you call them
navier-stokes or should you call them
the fundamental fluid equations and
there's a tension there I mean first of
all I'll say that you do want to give a
name the big win is giving the thing a
name because that makes a unit of
thought for the students so net so
that's the most that's the first-order
bit the first-order term the second
order term is should you how should you
name it and there there's something
which is that you want to Nate a name
that's common so if for example people
look it up elsewhere they're likely to
find more stuff about it on the other
hand you want a name that's intuitively
meaningful so there's a tension there's
not often a right answer to that and you
can go either way so for example I
wouldn't probably use constitutive
equation for the solid because I have to
think what the hell does constitutive me
so myself it doesn't mean anything to me
I'm like it's sort of like whenever
there's another word that try to
remember what is epistemology every time
I hear the word epistemology people just
use it like it's just a plain obvious
word but every time I hear it I have to
think what the hell does that mean and
then I have to put it in the translation
into the sentence they're saying and
then I can sort of parse what they're
saying so a constitutive equation in my
mind that's a word that is meaningful to
the experts and not so much to the
students so I would maybe call it the
idea of spring equation because it is
the ideal spring equation it's just
there's the proportionality and is
slightly general because you have
tensors but otherwise it is the ideal
spring equation so it connects to
something and you can say okay who does
you cover it it hooks so we often called
it Hookes law so then they have both and
there's no harm in doing that question
like if you are going to teach something
many times
yeah the spiral yeah
today's topics negative then he'll gas
right I mean okay people to be like lie
or like just for the sake of feeling do
you want to say that whether you can
actually reduce a equation in some cases
or
you could you tell me your name
sister yeah yeah thank you all right
that's a excellent question as well so
the question is how much should you lie
if at all you know for example if I'm
recommending teaching the big ideas in
the overall approach first that's almost
necessarily going to involve some amount
of line because you know the truth is
complex and messy the full truth so the
flips yeah and basically you do want to
lie so there's a some people hate it but
there is actually a really good book
that follows this principle and the even
if you're not interested in the
typesetting system you can see how it's
played out in this book it's called the
tech book so it's the manual for the
tech typesetting system which I use and
many people in math and physics use now
the reason it's interesting is that
Knuth actually he tells you in the
preface I'm going to lie to you so in
the so what he does is he has three
levels of statements there's statements
that aren't marked with a so there's
that sign that means on the road it
means slippery you know you might I see
something like there's a car my fishtail
basically a danger so there's statements
without one of these which may have some
lies in it not the full truth so did you
just get the idea what are the
fundamental concepts that Tech uses when
he starts to get into some gory details
but not super gory he puts one of those
bends and when he has super gory details
there's two of those bends and then he
says look don't read any of these things
unless you've been working with tech for
a year and are pretty confident with it
don't worry about that you'll be able to
do what you need to do just by reading
this and maybe the single Bend sections
so that's an example where the lying was
put to really good use and yeah you
should lie in fact you have to lie there
is no way to avoid it
and the fact everything is a lie there's
nothing big it has to be right because
to understand the universe right our
brains are a constituent of the universe
so there's no way to understand
the full universe because that would
involve packing more than our brain
capacity into our brain so just there
there's a proof pigeonhole principle
proof that you have to lie to understand
the universe so you have to say some
stuff that isn't quite true and you can
you and where the art is is in choosing
what is a useful lie so what you want to
do is develop the art of skillful lying
and that's a mark of a really really
good teacher is too skillful lying yes
you I probably am how did the question
is how do I know how do you know that
I'm not lying to you now I probably am
the reason being that I've now practiced
lying so much I don't even know when I'm
lying and when I'm not so no I'll give
you an example I am definitely lying to
some extent for example there probably
are situations where lying is you know
you don't want to do any lies at all for
example in the teaching people how to
manipulate the machines in the intensive
care unit maybe maybe the first thing
you need if you have a half an hour to
teach them you better teach them
memorize these damn things and don't
mess it up or kill somebody
maybe there's situations where lying is
less important and lying is more
important than I haven't talked about
those so right away I have lied to you
just on that base because of that and
I've skipped details because I wanted to
get the big idea across so the light
lying actually comes very naturally to
me because I think the most important
thing is the big details so just by
saying big details first you're
automatically lying and I'm recommending
it highly to you to where we go
as a student I feel I mean I asked to
another present
but one that was I think the
differentiating factor this is when they
tell you that there are
right so okay so the comment is that
students often don't like when they find
out that they've been lied to but it's
okay if you tell them that you're lying
to them and there's a general principle
there which is that which is you can use
in all your teaching which is that
whenever you do anything slightly
non-traditional so whenever you do
anything like that it's really important
to tell the students what you're doing
and why because they will go with you
they'll go along with you if you explain
to them the motive for it so you tell
them look this is a really complex
subject there is no way to understand
the whole subject at his first glance
you need to develop high-level
structures first and then you can put in
the details underneath that so I'm going
to tell you just the high level
structures first and there'll be some
untruths in that but they won't be
things I'm not I'm not going to tell you
things that are completely false that
you have to unlearn I'm going to tell
you things that you have to refine your
understanding of or that aren't the
whole truth so together with the idea of
a lie you want to minimize stuff that
you tell them that they have to unlearn
and make it so that you're telling them
stuff that they can keep using it's just
not the full story okay so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give you an
example just a quick example of another
equation and how you could teach it then
we'll take a short break and then we'll
do misconceptions okay so the other
equation that I was going to that I want
to explain is this one
and so I did a biology example before so
I chose a physics equation this time
which is the wave equation
okay now also to vary it with the
biology example I introduced it with a
bit of history with the wave equation
I'm going to actually introduce it with
a different approach which is not to
talk about the history but actually to
get the students to try to construct the
equation okay so the question is what
the hell is the wave equation well the
wave equation describes so here's some
string and E here is your coordinate X
and you want to know how does the height
of this piece here the height being f of
X as a function of time as well change
with position and with time so you want
to figure out an equation for that
behavior of that string that's stretched
between two points like for example this
might be a guitar string and these are
the two ends of the guitar string and
it's under tension and you want to know
how does it move okay so we're going to
construct the equations
so this could be let's say this is a
differential equations class for people
in physics who are learning mathematical
methods and they want to learn how to
construct differential equations so
maybe they're engineers physicists in
there say juniors so they have some
mathematical sophistication and some
knowledge of forces and physics and some
knowledge of differential equation so
I'm gonna write down the rough form of
the equation and we're gonna try to
figure out all the pieces and fill in
the missing pieces so
so I'm gonna give the general form of
the thing so there's some derivatives of
f with respect to time one or two
derivatives we're not sure is equal to
something here and then there's some
constant here or maybe here okay so
there's a whole bunch of question marks
to fill in and we're gonna do is reason
about what they are okay
so first question is to figure out this
guy how many time derivatives do we need
so we're what we're what this equation
describes is the motion of this point
now why does the point move okay well
you could ask the class and eventually
they'll come up with well there's some
forces on it because it's the strings
under tension so there's forces on the
point so here is our point and here's
say the string going through it this is
a blow up now of this region
okay so now what are the forces on this
guy well there's a force from that piece
of the string and a force from that
piece of this string okay because
there's force what's going to happen to
the thing is it going to have a velocity
or an acceleration any one acceleration
okay how many derivatives does
acceleration have two okay so we're
gonna put two derivatives here so you
need to do River so this and now we're
gonna say this is some kind of
acceleration okay and maybe there's
masses in there and stuff which all be
slurped into these constants so we have
an acceleration and now we have to
decide what generates acceleration right
is this side is generating the
acceleration or the force so we want to
decide for example one or two
derivatives
generally most equations either have one
derivative or - some really nasty ones
of four but generally it's one or two so
what do you choose is this one or two
okay then the last thing we're gonna do
is figure out the constant okay so now
one or two derivatives one way to decide
that is to make something that has just
one derivative in it so here is my
string and here is a point so this is a
this has F has a non zero so it has a
non zero df/dx
but
but the second derivative is zero okay
because it's a straight line okay so we
know the second derivative is zero let's
see what we can figure out what the
force or the acceleration should be okay
well here is a point there's going to be
a force on it from that end and that end
and what's the net result of these two
forces zero right so when the second
derivative is zero we in this cases at
least we would like the force to be zero
okay which means that force has to be
connected to second derivative of
position in K so we got that now the
next problem is to work out this what
goes here
the first thing is what's the sign
should it be plus or minus okay so I'm
gonna ask you that
so find a reason whether whether it
should be plus or minus here and a
reason so find a neighbor or two and
we'll take a vote plus or minus two
ative reason for it
so I can't use this example to decide
Oh okay let's vote
okay everyone have their votes ready who
votes for Plus okay so about who votes
for - okay that's great so we have a
diversity of opinion so right away what
that shows you is that it's worth
actually discussing that point right in
class because if you just tell people
they'll write down something you tell
them but they won't have actually
internalized it it'll just be something
that may be contradicted what they said
thought or not and they have to remember
was it what I thought it wasn't what I'd
not thought hmm what was it what I not
thought of what I thought right so they
don't actually understand why so it's
actually worth going through the
discussion so what example could you use
to decide who Evan I heard from yeah
could you tell me your name Mike yep
okay so let's use an arc like this right
we can't use this one because it's zero
and zero doesn't have a sign so it
doesn't help us so the next most
complicated thing is this so an arc like
that here's my point so it's gonna be
the forces downwards where the
acceleration is downwards so we should
have negative acceleration and what's
the second derivative with respect to
the position here that's also downwards
right because the arc is like that so
the derivative has the same direction
the space derivative and the
acceleration so it should be plus okay
so we got the sign right and to
emphasize the importance of getting the
signs there's an interesting comment
from Fineman back in the 60s at some
conference about quantum electrodynamics
he was commenting about how crazy the
whole process of that he invented for
solving quantum electrodynamics is and
his reason that is so crazy he said well
we do the first-order term and then we
calculate the second order term and add
it to the first order term but it's very
worrying that when we calculate the
second order term after the first order
term we don't know whether the second
order term is positive or negative
you just have to calculate it and see
what it's going to be but we can't
predict ahead of time whether it's
positive or negative and what that
speaks to is the importance that
physicists attach to knowing the sign of
an effect
is it plus or is it - and so that's
fundamentally important you want to make
sure you get that right now
why did I do the sign of the effect
after this after that order of the
derivatives because the most important
thing is what are the terms mean so this
is a curvature this is an acceleration
and until you so here let me write that
curvature until you know what the terms
mean there's no hope of figuring out
what the sign that connects them is so
that's the but the sign is the very next
thing you do and it's really important
some plus and now we need to put in one
more thing right because the dimensions
are totally bogus this is a position
divided by I x squared this is a
position divided by a length squared so
we need to actually multiply by
something to make the unit's come out
correct right so we need something that
puts a x squared here and a position
squared over here so then the units will
work out or position squared over x
squared which is C squared which is some
speed squared so speed squared is
position squared over x squared and that
makes all the units work out so there
you go there you have the wave equation
okay so now if you're gonna actually
formally derive it that's all fine but I
would do this first so that people know
what where every single term in the
equation comes from and now I've been a
bit sloppy these are really partial
derivatives but you know that's again
example of lying I wouldn't worry about
whether it's a partial or a total
derivative at the beginning because
that's not the fundamental idea fundable
idea is that it's curvature on this side
connecting to acceleration on this side
and they're connected by a positive sign
and by something called C so that has
dimensions of speed squared which turns
out to be the speed at which the wave
lose okay so that's a way to introduce
yet another equation not related to the
history but actually connecting to the
intuitive approach okay any questions
about that